a wildfire burning out of control in
northern Arizona triggered evacuation
orders for at least 3,000 people the
tinder fire which started Friday has
damaged or destroyed 20 to 30 buildings
Governor Doug Ducey declared a state of
emergency yesterday so far flames have
burned more than 14 square miles
david beg no is near the wildfire and
clint's well northeast of Phoenix David
good morning good morning this is as
close as we can get you we're being held
about 20 miles away from where the fire
is burning in an area where there are
more animals than humans look it's cold
here 39 degrees but despite that the
fire is burning out of control driven
mainly by the wind and that's part of
the reason why there is 0% containment
this morning nearly 500 firefighters
work overnight under a full moon to keep
the tender fire at bay dark smoke could
be seen from about 600 miles away near
Denver Colorado
that's according to a local county
sheriff there strong winds and dry
conditions are fanning the flames
homeowner Harry Spackman was advised to
evacuate all the sudden it was almost
like an explosion and the black smoke
was coming up the Red Cross is providing
relief to families that have been forced
out of their homes an estimated 600
people have already been evacuated
across ten communities fear is I go back
and everything's lost I mean if that's
case we lost everything we own John
Gregory says he felt helpless trying to
save his mother's home he was packing up
her belongings when rescuers came in and
told him to stop and get out was
disbelief is this really gonna happen
our house is gone I don't believe this
is happening we got to get out of here
we had to get out now now fire officials
have told us they know homes have been
destroyed they just don't know exactly
how many John as for the cause of the
fire it's believed to be man-made the
question is was it arson or was it an
accident
David beg no thanks